So this is something I didn't end up having
time for.
Earlier this week.
But I did want to get to it because it's a
preview of what we can expect next week in
the vice presidential debate between Kamala
Harris and Vice President Mike Pence.
When the Trump tax story broke, we learned,
thanks to The New York Times, that Trump paid
no federal taxes in 10 of the last 15 years,
paid only 750 dollars total in federal taxes
in 2016 and in 2017.
But we also learned about Donald Trump's debts.
And we talked about these earlier in the week.
Three hundred million dollars in loans that
come due during what would be Trump's second
presidential term if he gets one.
Four hundred and twenty million dollars in
total debt.
Likely one point one billion in total debt.
If you include other debts and and with which
we outlined earlier in the week, Joe Biden's
vice presidential nominee, Kamala Harris,
California Democratic senator, went on MSNBC
is Lawrence O'Donnell program and pointed
out the real threat of Trump owing people
money.
Take a look at this video clip.
This is why the American people deserve to
have a full accounting of the financial interest,
including the indebtedness of the president
of the United States.
And I and I do share in that concern.
Who does he owe the money to?
Tell us, who do you owe the money to?
We need to know that the American people have
a right to know that when the president of
the United States acts, he acts with their
priorities in mind, not what his priorities
in mind, of course, later on.
This was clarified, including in our segments
about it yesterday.
Donald Trump's debts are a national security
risk.
We talked about that.
Now, Kamala Harris was slammed by some people
because we do know about some of Donald Trump's
debts and some of Donald Trump's debts are
to banks that are household names, Deutsche
Bank and others.
Those publicly known and acknowledged debts
are not really the concerning ones.
Those are often tied to a specific property
or a mortgage.
And there's at least relative transparency
about them.
The ones that are the big question marks are
the ones that are from the period 2006 to
2014.
And that was a time when Donald Trump was
spending huge amounts of cash that he doesn't
tend to have, as we're learning.
And he spent huge amounts of cash buying or
developing or improving properties.
And for a long time, there's been a general
question about where the hell the cash came
from.
And now with the bombshell New York Times
story, we only have more questions about where
did the cash come from, given how precarious
Donald Trump's financial position appears
to be based on the documents that The New
York Times obtained.
When we find out and as we did previously,
when we know that Donald Trump paid two hundred
million dollars in cash to renovate that Turnberry
golf course in Scotland, where did 200 million
in cash come from?
Because it doesn't appear that Donald Trump
had it.
And now there is even more skepticism about
it.
Trump is claiming, hey, we just had 200 million
in cash sitting around, but it is extraordinarily
difficult to believe that's the case now.
And indeed, people who know Donald Trump's
businesses and his finances have said there's
no way Trump had 200 million in cash, particularly
at that time.
You can check out Adam Davidson's work for
The New Yorker as one example of someone who
really understands the finances of Trump and
the Trump Organization.
And to be clear, we don't know that these
are particularly sketchy debts tied to Trump's
claim of having all this cash.
We just know that at a sort of general level,
it's not believable that Trump had this cash
at the time.
We don't know where the cash came from.
And we know that Trump owes a ton of money.
So so it's it's all of those three things
put together.
Now, beyond that, not all of Trump's Deutsche
Bank debts are created equal.
There are these Deutsche Bank debts that,
like I said, are tied to a specific mortgage,
to a specific property.
But at some point during that same period,
2006 to 2014, Donald Trump went in the direction
of private banking at Deutsche Bank.
And at that point, the paper trail starts
to get shadier and shadowy here, and we just
lack a lot of information about it.
So there's sort of a double bottom line here.
Two different bottom lines.
One bottom line is now with the revelations
of The New York Times bombshell tax story.
Are there even more questions about who Trump
owes money to, where he got outrageous amounts
of cash that don't seem to fit his financial
situation during that period?
Oh, six to 14 you.
Absolutely.
Even more questions about it which raise even
more national.
Curity questions in terms of a Trump who could
be could be manipulable or subject to coercion
because of the amount of money that he owes.
Yes.
The second bottom line is, is this going to
matter in terms of the 2020 election?
I hate to say it, particularly with more time
now having passed since the Sun story.
I think the answer is no.
I do not think at this point in time that
Donald Trump is going to be hurt in any significant
way by The New York Times bombshell tax story.
And what's crazy about that is for years we've
been saying the suspicion is Trump pays no
or very little taxes.
Trump's not as wealthy as he thinks, as he
claims to be.
Trump owes a lot of people money.
It was all proven true by The New York Times
bombshell story.
And yet the people who care are mostly already
not voting for Donald Trump and the people
who are voting for Donald Trump aren't going
to be influenced by it either way.
So as much as it pains me to say it because
of what it says about the American voting
public at this point, and it says something
very, very bad and sad, I don't think that
the tax story is going to make a difference
if you disagree with me.
I want to hear from you.
And again, as far as debates are concerned,
V.P. debate on Wednesday, Kamala Harris versus
Mike Pence, I predict there will be fewer
interruptions from Pence than what we saw
from Donald Trump.
And I expect Kamala Harris is going to absolutely
hammer on Mike Pence.
I'm actually looking forward to it, not in
a car crash way, but in an actually we might
get some policy discussion sort of way.
That'll be next Wednesday.
Hope you'll join me
on YouTube, Twitter and Facebook.